let's jump to the story um about
censorship we have this from timcast.com
patreon bans users for content on other
platforms without warning yep this week
patreon which hosts paid content for
creators has banned two well-known
creators from its platform for
appearances and content shared on other
media platforms on tuesday sydney watson
host of you are here i've heard of that
show on blaze tv was banned from the
platform watson does not regularly post
content to the site but was banned over
hate speech according to a notice from
patreon watson's program on blaze tv
covers current topics just disney
employee walkouts i think we know that
plus we have elijah here so we can we
can move on and we also had um josh uh
location is that you pronounce it late
cash i think cash yeah he was banned
hours after appearing on infor so these
are two accounts but it's not just you
know these individuals on patreon it's
also tucker carlson got censored on
twitter
and
uh charlie kirk and the babylon b so it
looks like we're starting to see
censorship kicking back up for a while
there there was a small lull right
censorship was huge news for a long
period of time all of a sudden now the
the reason i would say it looks like
we're starting to see things kick into
high gear is that tucker carlson getting
censored is big i mean he's prominent
but seeing sydney watson get her patreon
banned when she doesn't even post to it
is very interesting to me why would they
shut down sydney's patreon here's my
thoughts
she was getting about a thousand bucks a
month from patreon passively this helps
sydney exist and do work and be
influential the midterm elections are
coming up and just one month ago mike
bloomberg said the democrats are going
to get wiped out the polls are showing
as the past few months democrats are
getting wiped out mike bloomberg was
interesting because he said the reason
they're going to get wiped out is
because americans perceive democrats as
being too obsessed with cultural issues
and not economic issues well why would
people believe that i mean if you watch
the mainstream media
sure you might hear like cnn msnbc we'll
talk some about the democrats but for
the most part no they're trying to prop
them up it's channels like ours it's
shows like yours elijah with sydney that
are bringing up the cultural issues
democrats are engaged in what the
schools are actually fighting for the
teachers are trying to keep these things
a secret they don't want parents to know
about it if the parents didn't know
about it they'd probably not think
democrats were fighting for it because
people like you or i expose this stuff
there's a perception growing among
regular voters that democrats are
obsessed with cultural issues then they
ban sydney watson seemingly out of the
blue for no reason why they want to
start stripping away influence like we
saw in 2018 the first patreon purge it
happened just after the midterms i think
just around the same time as the
midterms we saw carl benjamin get booted
and then all of a sudden a bunch of
people staged a mass exodus i think it
may have been before the midterms
actually it's no surprise that right
before democrats start losing their
allies in big tech and media start
coming after prominent influencers who
are making democrats look bad
yeah you know first of all on the sydney
issue we have to focus on this i'll
comment on josh in a second
but number one that sydney didn't use
the platform or post anything anymore is
clear evidence that she didn't do
anything
wrong on the platform we know that
patreon does ban for activity outside
the platform in fact i ended up doing a
meeting and pretending to be a take one
of their
user meetings with their engineer team
and pretend like i cared and i recorded
this i don't know if i should say that
but ended up recording the audio and
kept asking them questions of of whether
or not that they were trying to publish
it so this is not illegal hopefully uh
but i also was like i was talking to
them and i genuinely years ago like what
2018 are about i think of 2018 i was
like hey i just want to know if you guys
are for free speech and every time i
would ask them a question they would
just kind of like dodge it and it was
nothing came of it matt christensen got
on a call recorded it years ago do you
remember the 2018 when matt christensen
like recorded his phone call whatever
yeah yeah so he literally got on there
and when he was asked about it whether
to free split if they care about free
speech they were just like i don't know
so basically they didn't want to answer
so i looked back i had tweets in 2018
saying i gotta leave and my first tweet
of january 1st of 2019 was like my goal
this year is to leave patreon and i did
and i lost thousands of dollars
prematurely because i knew that this
would happen but with sydney watson
there's three things that are really
vital here number one
sydney is not a religious zealot nut
right-wing extremist you know person
some white straight male that we got to
get off because it's going to bring the
nationalist fascist government back
sydney is a cultured
atheist very well-spoken well-researched
individual who mostly just puts out on
her own channel hyper-researched
well-thought-out scripted videos she has
no history of making extremist
statements she's never part of been a
part of an extremist group the closest
thing she's ever done to extremism was
run a men's right conference in
australia another country for their
rights and to fight for them which was
controversial in australia which
everything's controversial there but
more importantly the ironic part is we
run a show together now and the whole
reason why we run a show together she's
the same one who actually brings some
logic and some straightforwardness and
helps keep me back in reality where she
lives while i'm out in space so it's
like cindy's reputation
is actually for being calculated for
thinking things through and she's known
for if she doesn't know stuff will say i
actually haven't researched that i don't
know that so you're taking just a normal
girl who's literally from australia who
doesn't have a history of anything gets
deleted you know it's targeting for a
specific reason and i i'm wondering
though with this as they deleted her i
wonder if they're just testing who else
they can delete because if they can get
somebody who doesn't post but is still
making money i feel like it gives them
the green light to go well let's go
after other people too there's no
evidence nothing happens i mean it was
it was three and a half years ago
you know we had we saw these
conversations i will say for sydney i i
reached out to her she said it was like
i asked if it was like a background
thing for her meaning she has it it's
available to people but she doesn't
actively post there so it exists but
it's not like she was using the platform
and ran afoul of their rules so
as for for josh i really have to
question why he was on patreon josh uh
lakesh lakota you know you know are you
familiar with wrong opinion podcast i'm
not familiar but i would like to comment
on sydney very quickly before you move
on to josh i would just say that uh this
is the soft introduction to people
getting banned from banks which we're
already seeing here in america look at
what just happened in canada sorry go
ahead well no no no um the point i was
bringing up with josh is that all of
this happened almost four years ago i
think it's fair to say three and a half
years ago because it was three three
years and five months yeah so for uh
cindy to get banned she got banned for
what uh carl benjamin got banned for the
exact same thing
off platform behavior
so so again i'll say this like what what
did she do do you have no clue she
existed well for for sydney she's not
she wasn't using patreon as like her
core income
and so you know i don't really care if
you have a patreon right now and you're
like oh i don't really care about i
don't even think twice if it's gone it's
gone it's here it's whatever there's
money i'm like okay i get it but the
reason i brought up josh is that he put
his career on a platform where over
three years ago
lauren southern was nuked overnight
without warning and then carl benjamin
the ceo said we'll never do this again
we will issue warnings to people let
them know because we don't want to take
their income and then someone dug up a
live stream where carl benjamin was
making a point about he was arguing with
people who he says were alt-right and so
he used a racist term to describe them
and his point was you are exactly the
way you described these people for that
patreon banned his account without
warning for off-platform behavior
and then reported that you know he said
a racial slur and got banned
three years later josh is still using
the platform i mean like at a certain
point there is
i think it's wrong they shouldn't
abandon them but it's almost it's also
like bro if you if you if like antifa
puts up a big flyer saying we're having
an antifa party and we're gonna beat up
elijah schaefer and elijah schaefer's
like i'm going to go to that that was my
job for like 18 months no but i mean
like specifically saying like true like
good career choice like this built like
it's one thing to be in a public space
that everyone's allowed to access but
patreon is a private company that i do
understand and the moment they took
action against lauren and carl i was
like i'm out red flag yeah after lauren
i i actually talked to the ceo and he
was like dude we're trying you got to
understand i argued with him and i even
i even you know
i'm pretty sure he didn't even know what
he was talking about when it came to
lauren southern when i talked to him
when it happened with carl benjamin i
was like this dude lied to us so they
invited us into their business let's say
it was a sandwich shop that had a big
sign saying elijah shaffer will get
punched in the face it's like would you
go in there you know like you know
they're coming after you it's a monday
or like they're going to spit in your
food they're not right i know what
you're saying like there are there are
so many opportunities i think you've
seen too where like genuinely and i
i want to hear sam's opinion on this
someone who is just fresh off the w
train uh
is where
i do get i totally understand this i
have a hard time commenting since i run
primarily my career on youtube and i
know youtube hates me and i know that i
could lose my channels any second and i
know we're all kind of playing that game
i would say i think josh just probably
bet on the fact that i don't mean this
disrespectfully to him that it's more of
a niche smaller podcast he's not lauren
southern he's not going on some ship
crews and wearing it's okay to be white
t-shirts into australia and whatnot he's
not doing these things he's not getting
the national press he's got a niche pod
podcast and i love lauren southern so
much but but i meant like he's got you
got this way worth you think well i'm
probably
beyond scrutiny like even sydney or
whatever is raising in in her profile
she's been very successful recently uh
and throughout her her her career i
think she'll eventually be at a million
subs pretty soon and so she could be a
target but not me and so that's what
we're kind of seeing like with sav where
it's like and i'm not mean this to
disrespect to you either where savs
learn this the hard way is like it
doesn't matter how big you are it
matters what you're doing it really does
it's inverted actually the bigger you
are the harder it is to ban you because
it makes too big of a splash that's why
when it came to learn to code twitter
mostly banned smaller accounts
so when the learn to code thing was
happening and they were banning people
it was mostly people with a few hundred
followers who are just engaging and
sharing and talking i tweeted learn to
code several times
nothing ever happened to me my account
was just too big it would have been too
big of an issue and they said oh no so
they can get rid of as many of these
conservatives as possible saying learn
to code and none of them are big enough
to actually make a splash that's what
they're going for so
banning josh is actually entirely
predictable if you were a small creator
if you're a new channel with maybe only
100 to several thousand followers and
you go on youtube you'll be banned in
two seconds if you go on patreon you'll
be banned in two seconds this is why i
say if you're just starting out now
rumble is the place to be
absolutely rumble or mines but rumble is
going to be growing plus there's locals
integration with rumble i've got my
issues with locals but they're still
substantially better than patreon i
can't imagine like there's no reason you
couldn't just go to locals you know you
build your business on the platform of
someone who expressly says like we're
going to destroy you and we want to and
then you're shocked when they do well
and that's the thing too that we all
should have learned from alex jones
being banned right it was alex jones he
was crazy he was a conspiracy theorist
everyone was like yeah yeah he deserves
to be banned no one else is going to get
banned and then as the years have
progressed we've seen more and more
people get banned and like you just
talked about tim you know if you're an
independent journalist who's just
getting into the game
you are not going to make it if you're
willing to tell the truth you're not
going to make it if you're actually
trying to go out on the street and go
get those interviews and go viral it's
very difficult i mean yeah yeah rumble
sure um it's growing it's a new platform
but i mean think about the fact that you
candace owens elijah schaefer steven
crowder a lot of these big names you
guys got really popular back in the day
when youtube was still the wild wild
west when you could still say whatever
you wanted on twitter now it's really
difficult to break into the space unless
you're on an alternative platform like
truth social or locals rumble all that i
i agree i disagree um i got big well
after the censorship was taking effect i
mean my my main growth was in 2019. so
that's what it hit to the major news
show yeah about youtube yeah they were
they they uh it was 2018 in may when
youtube nuked my channels across the
everyone's channels got nuked across the
board and it was only last year the
censorship got removed on google for tim
cast so we actually were hindered for a
long time i think the issue was that for
one i'm i'm a workaholic i was work i
was producing
i think four hours of content every day
more than any other talk radio host or
podcaster and weekends with no days off
that helped me kind of push through this
barrier they're setting up
and then last year i mentioned on this
show that you couldn't even google
search tim cast the channels or any of
our videos if that if you took the title
of one of our segments and put it in
google facebook would come up you could
even try and search for youtube and then
immediately after that the next day the
filters were removed
so we actually went through all of that
we had the the alternative influencer
network study that was published by all
these major outlets that tried claiming
i was the center no joke of like this
vast network of the alt-right or
something craziest thing ever claimed
that i had done segments of people i'd
never met before claimed that chris
raygun
had had coordinated with richard spencer
like the levels of lies chris reagan who
chris raygun oh i don't know who that is
you know the song punch a nazi
no
yelled at me before i end up getting it
it's a satirical song based on paparazzi
by lady gaga where he mocks the left for
thinking everyone's a nazi he did delete
he unlisted the video because i guess
the left told him it was bad and he like
apologized or something for and removed
it which i think is ridiculous and silly
because it was a great point he was
making but uh
the point being the true era of free
speech on youtube was 2006. after after
google bought them in 2000 and 2006
there was about four months and then
they made their first band and it was
warren 25. go back and watch warren 25
videos if you can find any of them he
had to change his name warren 25 smash
he came back then they banned that he
would swear profanities of george bush
to end the war just this canadian dude
oh so lit and he gave me inspiration to
speak my mind dude i get so sad that
i'll never get to experience youtube
editing come on you can go back and
watch it avocado a lot of late nights
video chatting avocado his name was
literally not the nikk it was n-i-g-g-a
and avocado he's a white guy on youtube
for a long time and then he was it
wasn't even as bad as this now all he
had to come out was be like yo i didn't
know we weren't supposed to be using the
n-word in our names and then everyone
was like cool and he's still popular
he's like one of the most viral people
in the world he's like sorry try doing
that today start call yourself n word
cast irl it's not gonna work there is no
peak of youtube there there isn't one i
mean maybe we'll see it once youtube's
completely obliterated but uh i was at
the tribeca film festival ceremony thing
i got invited to back in i think 2012.
this is 20 i'm pretty sure this is 2012.
and there was this very popular youtube
group i'll keep let them keep their
privacy and they were talking to me
about how they were like man youtube
used to be amazing back in like 2009
2010 they were like we put up a video
and we'd get like 5 million views now
we're lucky if we get half a million
that was in 2012 they were saying that
vice they got all of their big play on
their documentaries in like 09 and 2010
and then after that it's like on average
they get like 50 000 now so people are
like the the oh man the best time was
four or five years ago no there's
there's there's no
it's getting bad it's getting worse
but i think the reality is
right now the latter is being pulled up
behind you there are different periods
where everyone thinks like this period
was the peak this period was the peak i
don't know when the peak was to be
honest maybe 2012 but maybe not even
because your real opportunity for
virality in the era of reddit and and
youtube this is how you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna leave people's names out of it
but there's a very prominent podcast
that's like spiraling out of control and
failing with you know this he's like the
host is sitting in the room i'm like but
i won't point fingers yeah no no no no
no it's it's a very it's a big podcast
i'm going to leave their name out of it
because what they would do is they would
manipulate reddit to uh get youtube
traction and it worked
so you'd like there are certain things
everyone knew reddit wanted and it was
very very easy to gamify the reddit
upvote and downvote system and so
people people who didn't know about this
like politicians and big companies
didn't know how to gamify reddit
so it was just savvy people who had been
on the internet figured out how to
exploit it to make themselves famous and
they did and there was this period where
if you were smart and you had the
ability you'd make it happen
now i agree with you we're at a point
where it's you can't do it the latter's
being pulled up behind everybody if
you're really good you can find a way
but i i will say we're at a point where
the ladder's gone go on rumble well but
here's here's the fundamental issue and
this is what's so insane to me of how
this is backfiring because i feel like i
just squeezed in in the last second it
was like the last ditch effort and one
of the other people that squeezed in
sydney squeezed in john doyle squeezed
in this 2018 year this is right before
it got really bad in 2019 if you got in
on 2018 you essentially you know in the
terms of the girl getting passed around
the team you were the fourth or fifth in
but you still made it into into the game
into the party it's true you still got
something and we got action and a lot of
our channels aren't as big as other
channels we face a lot of stuff but i'm
grateful and i'm grateful for what i
have i'm grateful for the career god
gave me and i'm happy about that but
here's where i'm not happy
i'm upset and it makes me angry because
they have done
two things that is both unforgivable and
is going to damage our country as a
whole and i don't think it can be undone
number one by shutting the door to
individual creators that was their point
is to take away independent media
because not just the right wing but as
we see with like russell brand or joe
rogan people who are not right wing but
are inherently open to ideas which is
now becoming a right-wing idea i don't
know if you saw today that uh msnbc says
that
exercise is a right-wing idea which i
actually kind of agree with but i will
say that they shut the door because i'm
it's a joke but okay anyway so so they
shut up they shut the door to
independent and small media and that was
always their their plan my my new pa um
uh josiah moody who started he was like
hey i was like yeah tucker at his peak
we'll get you know three 3.5 million
views he goes yeah but have you seen his
youtube it's crushing and i go yeah bro
let me tell you about this one thing
called authoritative news sources where
they you know gave all the all the news
media
basically all of the views that we would
all get so number one that shut it out
and that doesn't allow us to have ideas
it gives the uh mainstream media control
of the internet which they didn't have
in our country but the worst part about
this is and you'll know this the worst
part about this
let's say you're new and you want to
come up well the way that you want to
come up in your new and your political
you can't go with the views model unless
you work for mainstream media so you've
got to build a cult following a cult
following will always reward more
extreme ideas and not only will it
reward more extreme ideas but it'll
actually push you into corners into more
niche avenues which will make somebody
try to appeal to a more extreme
perspective and i see this happening all
across the board especially with gen z
is that they've become very
authoritarian
on left and the right the people that
they like to watch that are more like
you know demonetized ban on twitch
either they're pushing straight up
fascism or communism they're pushing
absolute authoritarianism and what you
do is the only place that you can grow
you can go on to like you can go on to
any of these uh you know site apps where
people have fundamentally more extreme
views now what that does is it means if
you want to find someone who's young who
thinks like you who's a new creator tim
paul sucks elijah sucks sav sucks ian
sucks okay i don't want to hear these
millennial people whatever get the hell
out where's my gen z you've got a few
options and i'm not going to name them
on the screen you've got a few options
i'm telling you you're not getting
kosher ideas those are fringe ideas some
of them you know whether you agree with
them or not you have one option so
they're creating an extremist pipeline
that they say they're trying to ban and
that's what makes it sad is a young guy
goes well i want to be a right-wing
podcaster if you're espousing charlie
kirk's views ben shapiro's views you
aren't going to get anywhere you're
going to have to go as far right or as
far left as possible you're going to
have to appeal to the extreme base focus
on small donations and then we start
breeding these little like cosmic groups
of people who are in an echo chamber and
they all think they're right they're
completely detached from any of the
mainstream narrative any of the
independent media and they're doing
their own thing and i feel like we've
lost them they hate us all by the way
gen z hates like they really genuinely
do like hate the millennials and all the
other creators they're like very
because you don't have like a good gen z
youtuber that comes on your show and
then you're debating and you're on his
channel we just don't have that there's
like a cutoff it's like 25 years old and
everyone under that is now in their own
niche and we have a divide politically
and i don't know what they're up to
until i go to their their their
streaming sites and i'll watch them and
i'm like
oh crap
like i mean from charlie kirk to now i'm
glad we've gotten more like open to
discussing ideas charlie kirk is gen z
isn't he no he's my age 28 so he's
millennial 28's millennial yeah for sure
i think 27 6 is the cutoff for 25 is the
cut off oh okay but but i was gonna say
yeah under 25 i'm going i'm not it's not
that all their ideas are wrong i'm just
going oh we went here that quickly it's
been four years and we're now talking
about the authoritarian takeover of the
country and getting rid of the
constitution installing a king and like
i'm just an amano you know you know
religious state i'm going how did we
jump in five years from hey let's talk
about h-1b visas and talk about you know
immigration moratoriums to a catholic
christian dumb it's not that these
people are any i'm not scared of them or
anything i was going oh crap that was a
fast acceleration thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there